all right I want to tell you guys about
something that's been sort of going on
behind the scenes at the show and maybe
it'll be interesting to you and it has
everything to do with people in my
audience who are never going to be
satisfied with this program for lack of
a better term and maybe naively over the
last few months maybe I thought that I
could satisfy them in some way and this
doesn't apply to everybody but there are
also people in the audience that
probably I should sort of be apologizing
to in the sense that I I think that my
naivete on this issue may have made the
show worse for some of you over the last
few months and here's the realization
that we've sort of come to as a point of
departure for what we're talking about
today it's become very clear over the
last I would say acutely the last three
months but more bigger picture over the
last year that there's a slice of the
left that's never going to be satisfied
with this program unless I just become a
different person with totally different
views and a different moral grounding
and essentially M no longer me and the
show is no longer this program now of
course the entire right is dissatisfied
with this program other than the people
who write to me and say I don't agree
with anything you say but I I just I
watch to see what your take is and I
appreciate you being honest about it but
in terms of the positions I take of
course the right doesn't agree with
almost anything that I say on this
program but there's also a contingent on
the left which is far louder in the
sense in a sense because they are at
least you know a nominally part of my
side as the term is that is never going
to be satisfied with this program unless
I just abandon everything I believe in
take their positions so before I get to
that I told the story years I mean I've
been telling the story over the years
many times when I started the David
Pakman show back then it was called
mid-week politics it was just a one a
Wednesday program I was absolutely
horrified that somebody might write to
me and be mad that I said something they
disagree with or they might leave an
angry youtube comment or something like
that it was scary to me and I sort of
tried to play the show down the middle
for a while for a few weeks where I
would report the news and I would say
the left says this and the right
this and kind of leave it there and it
was a very boring show and it was also
unsatisfying because of course I had
opinions and I was keeping them to
myself and not really stating them
because of this fear and also people got
mad anyway right people people disagreed
that there were two sides to many
stories and they were mad that I
presented both sides as if they were
equal so the point is I quickly realized
that that couldn't be the show it wasn't
a satisfying way to me to do the show
and it wasn't very useful either because
I have an opinion that I want to get out
there so that this very quickly became
an opinion program and of course now I'm
used to the attacks and the anti-semitic
comments and thousands of mm-hmm excuse
me angry angry YouTube comments a day or
whatever the case may be but over the
last three to twelve months it's become
very clear that there is now a slice of
the left that is not going to accept any
position other than their position and
they won't stop calling me a DNC shill
or other terms unless I take their
positions and what I want to tell you
today is that it's not going any further
you're not going to be satisfied with
this program and maybe this isn't the
program for you let me give you some
examples okay right now these are maybe
relevant examples one is the never Biden
crowd okay the never Biden crowd is
never going to be satisfied with what I
say unless I join them and say I'm never
gonna vote for Biden now I'm not going
to do that at this point based on what
we know it's conceivable Joe Biden could
go on a killing spree or something and
I'd change my mind
but it's become clear that no matter how
I couch the reality that based on
everything I know right now Biden's
clearly better than Trump and I plan to
vote for Biden I could talk about the
Supreme Court doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what I say unless I refuse to
vote for Biden there's a very loud
contingent that shows up on my Twitter
and reddit and whatever they're not
going to be happy now the good news is
they represent a pretty small portion of
my audience and a pretty small portion
of the left but this is not going to be
a program for these folks and they will
call me a Democratic DNC shill unless I
say never Biden which of course helps
Donald Trump not gonna do it let's talk
about another example this relates to a
woman named Tara Reid
Tara Reid says Joe Biden sexually
assaulted her in 1993 now there was a
period of about seven to ten days where
I had a contingent contacting me
increasingly angrily saying David you're
terrible you're a shill because you're
not covering her allegations now over
time more and more clips have published
to my youtube channel now I believe it's
six in total where Tara Reid's
allegations are discussed has this
satisfied this slice of the left no of
course not because I'm talking about
Tara Reid now but I'm not saying the
right thing which I guess is Joe Biden's
a rapist and I'm not voting for him but
of course I'm not going to say that Joe
Biden hasn't been convicted of rape he's
not even accused of rape if I understand
the allegations correctly and the
reality is that either Joe Biden or
Donald Trump are going to be President
of the United States on dozens of issues
I prefer Biden now this is not some big
theatrical defiant performance for me
I'm living my life I'm doing the show in
advocating for the policies I support
and in November I will essentially have
two choices and I've made clear as of
right now which choice I'm going to make
I've not attacked Tara Reid's
credibility I've not come out and said
her story makes no sense I've not done
any of those things but this contingent
didn't really want me to just talk about
Tara Reid they want me to say never
Biden and they won't be satisfied until
I say that this is no way to run a show
if I'm going to kowtow to these slices
of the left that are hell-bent on
getting specific statements out of me I
could do every show about Tara Reid but
it's not just about covering it it's
about taking their position and if I
don't I'm a DNC shill and a bad person
this probably isn't the show for you
we've seen this in some other cases as
well I won't spend a lot of time on
these but when it comes to the Maduro
regime in Venezuela you know I've
pointed out the rhetoric that started
with Hugo Chavez it was very left
populist rhetoric it became an
authoritarian nightmare a corrupt
judiciary it can't be trusted the
country's resources have been raped and
pillaged by elites to the exclusion of
the majority and people write to me and
say David how dare you support American
intervention in Venezuela and I say no
I'm from South America I'm very well
acquainted with the history of the
region that is
masters of American intervention but
Chavez was no hero and Maduro is no hero
and that they've been bad for the
country and they hate it so it's not
really about I support American
intervention which they know I don't
it's that I'm not praying at the altar
of Maduro they will never be satisfied
recently george w bush came out with
this just milquetoast statement about
unity around coronavirus and i said hey
george w bush is a war criminal but
compared to trump he sounds like a
normal person it's not praise of bush
i'm not rehabilitation as image and
immediately dozens of comments and
hundreds of Twitter and Facebook posts
saying you are rehabilitating the image
of a war criminal they will never be
satisfied unless I always say there is
no way in which Bush is better than
Trump
so my renewed effort is and this is my
pledge I don't care about what these
people think and I'm not going to let it
dictate the show you can leave me
comments on YouTube or tweet me write me
email you know whatever maybe this just
isn't the show for you like I I don't
watch political shows like mine but
there must be some show that takes these
positions right like if you're looking
for an ever Biden show is there a bite
and never Biden show out there I assume
there is or if you're looking for oh we
love Maduro show or I'm guessing that
these shows exist much like I can't open
the eyes of a devout trumpet they're
closed off
so are these leftists on this slice of
the left and it's sad but I can't
control it all I can control is my show
and I apologize that over the last three
months there's been a naivete where I
thought maybe there would be some way
but it doesn't seem like there is
they're not going to be satisfied
everybody should watch the shows they
want read what you want come to your
conclusion conclusions but we're gonna
do the show this way and that's the way
it's going to be now let's get to
something positive which relates to
really great changes for the show that's
the next thing if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my alt
favorite apps called blinka stinkiest
lets you consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic
to check it out on blinkin blink east
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25 percent off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video